[Music]
so
just be mindful of that one welcome
everybody i
have an apology from andrea
alan can i have somebody move that
though that apology be accepted
thank you john seconder
thanks mark all those in favor say aye
those against carried
any conflicts of interest tonight
right the minutes from the last meeting
can i have somebody to move those
minutes
thanks mark seconder
thank you phillip
gotta be faster andrew
any discussion around those
right all those in
i missed the first fact of the meeting
was actually working in my garden
i've been i've just touched the time i
could say
thank you for the apology john
all those in favor say aye
those against that's carried
any matters arising
we don't have any deputations and
presentations i don't think we've got
any adjoining business
report joanne and ally welcome
back again
good evening everyone so the purpose of
this report is to update the board on
the results from the speed limit
consultation and obtain a recommendation
for council this consultation was
carried out over a three week period and
the majority of respondents to this
award area favored changes and would end
in sefton with mixed results for the
unsealed roads in waikoku
even with the mixed responses received
for the roads in waikoku we're still
recommending that these roads are
reduced to 60 kilometers per hour
all of these roads are narrow and have
varying roadside hazards including areas
where there are minimal sight distance
the main operating speed is also under
40 kilometers per hour on all of the
roads and therefore a reduction in speed
limit will have little effect on the
road users
it is recommended that the board
recommends to the council that the
posted speed limits on all the rows
listed in tables one to three are
amended
have to take any questions
[Music]
right questions anybody
hi ali could you just confirm that all
the roads in woody in waikoku are
unsealed
yes they are right thank you
um i have one question around
as always comes out with speed limit
reviews people raise other
roads
one of the residents of sifton raised
lower sifton road
particularly he lives on the corner of
toppings road and lower sefton road
school bus stops here to pick
students up um it's a hundred k's that
road and that's the one with the
the uh
espn's and it is very shaded in the
winter um
early mornings is not great along that
road is that going to be looked at
at any time in the future
they compared it to
uh
gresson's road and said you know
gresson's road got dropped to 80. it is
still busy along that road because there
are more commuters now more people
has theft and changes and its dynamic
um
so there's
you know
lands getting subdivided uh people are
moving out from christchurch and
commuting into christchurch so
um so as part of the current review of
the setting of speed limit rules there
are some changes that are going to be
coming up or legislated likely to be
early next year at some stage
on how speed limits are set
and as part of that there will be a
requirement for councils to develop and
implement a speed management plan
which we'll look at
staged how councils will do a staged
addressing of speed limits
across the district over a period of
about 10 years
and so that aligns with the road to zero
strategy which is looking at
trying to reduce harm from accidents on
roads and setting safe and appropriate
speeds so
that's probably the long way of saying
yes we will be looking at
the district we're going to need to look
at the district wider
in terms of whether there are roads we
want to upgrade to
keep at 100 and whether there are roads
we feel need to be brought down to the
80s so yeah we'll be looking at the
entire district
thanks joanne two other questions um
tulles road what's happening with that
one is
because that came to the
last speed limit review i think
yeah and it's not included in this one
um it will be a future review and with
that one we'll also need to look at
whether we upgrade
um to
keep a higher speed because i'm pretty
sure ali correct me if i'm wrong it had
a safe and appropriate of 60 but we
didn't feel that that was appropriate
for the environment so what it might
need is some work in locations to
support the 80.
and well another question back to
sefton what do we have to do to get a
variable speed
sign outside the school for during
school hours
uh 40k flashing in school yeah okay um
so we will have a look at sefton um as
they're on the main road that you're
talking about so that is part of the
reduction obviously bringing the speed
down
um
we also as part of the
setting of speed limit rule and the
bringing safe and appropriate speeds
around schools we also have to implement
a program for the entire district of how
we will get our highest risk schools
down to either 30 or 40 kilometers
outside the schools for urban areas and
i think it was 60 for rural
so again we have we will be developing
over the next year a plan for what
that's going to look like and how we're
going to go about doing that so that
will very much be on our radar as part
of that exercise yeah because the
school's at the northern
end so it's very relatively close to the
100 kilometer
speed area yeah
and there is a lot of trucks on that
road
so
it is an issue that's been raised quite
a few times yeah yeah that's various
members of the board you've been out to
see this school yeah yeah
any other questions from anyone
you look like you're thinking mark no
question no um well i would i would like
to move that we
accept
all of those
speed limit changes
so a2
e
do i have a second of that thank you
mark
um i
am
moving that simply because
i think the speed limits make sense
we have talked about areas like copper
beach for some time copper beach road
evergreen place around gladstone road
petrie's road has that beca is becoming
more urbanized
you know we can't have the existing
speed limits it is just not safe
with the unsealed roads
waikoku the feedback was mixed
um but i also think
who goes a hundred kilometers an hour
down an unsealed road um it's not safe
particularly around kaiapoi priestess
road that is used by cyclists and
walkers
because it gets used as a loop track
between pegasus waikoku
and they often go one way along the
coastal track and then come back
along kaya boy power road um you've also
got kaiapoi pass sitting there so you've
got
um an historical site
um where people like to be able to walk
to it and
see it
so
for that reason i would be approving
them
do you have anything you'd like to say
mark
anybody else philip
ah thank you madam chair i'll be
supporting the recommendation
my default position is
leave speed limits alone unless there's
some reason for justifying a reduction
and
i have people saying to me oh what's the
point in putting in a submission you've
made your mind up
well i'd like to take the opportunity to
assure those people that i've read all
the submissions
and have taken them all into account as
i think we probably all have
i am surprised at the waikoku outcome
because that to me is a bit of a
no-brainer a hundred k's on the shingle
road um
and the average speed as joanne said
it's something in the order of 40k so
nobody's actually losing anything
one of these submitters did make a point
which i think is sometimes valid
and that is that it's the condition of
the road
sometimes we're lowering the speed limit
to avoid maintaining or upgrading the
road and i think that is a widely held
view
it's not always true but i'm inclined to
think in some instances
maybe
so um that is something we should bear
in mind um
we don't want to slow the traffic down
too much it does make new zealand lease
efficient if we go back to the days of
john key
and the road transport forum i think it
was
they don't like lower speed limits it
makes the economy lease efficient
but there is a case and i i'm quite
happy that these particular roads um
mirror
a reduction in speed
any other comments from anyone
i'll put that to the vote all those in
favor say aye
those against
is carried
i'd just like to say thank you very much
for
the report but i you know i mean as i
said to you just before that the
consultation document was really really
good it was well laid out
um
it was easy for people to see and if
even if they did it online you know you
could get into the
you know the part that
detained so
i mean it can't have been easy because
there was a lot of roads scattered all
over the district and
yeah i think it was a really good job
thank you
we'll let you go home
[Applause]
okay
right okay the meeting schedule
good evening everyone
um
your normal
report at this time of the year which is
laying out your schedule for
next year
um you will see that i have
made arrangements to meet at cefton and
at waikoku
um both of them in the early part of the
year mainly because both those are quite
elderly buildings and summer is probably
the best time
to use them
so
i will take any questions
questions from anyone
somebody to move
thanks mark seconded by andrew any
comment discussion
i'll just note that the february meeting
is on a tuesday
so just note that and um
in your diaries rather than a monday
because the sefton hall is used on a
monday night isn't it yeah that's the
reasoning
so i put that to the vote all those in
favor say aye
those against is carried
right correspondents got a thank you
letter from the life education trust so
it's a nice letter
have somebody
move that we receive that correspondence
thanks john seconded by philip
any discussion comments john
any other discussion from anyone
i'll put that to the vote all those in
favor say aye
those against that's carried by cheers
reporters there any questions from
anyone
i'll put that to the vote that that is
received
oh do i have a second or sorry i better
have a second i'll move it thanks mark
right put that to the vote all those in
favor say aye
those against
that's carried
uh matters for information is all laid
out there
any questions around any of those
we're not there yet john
the next item
so we're actually at the
matters for information so it's the
reports and documents that have come out
from council
so i would move that we receive that
information do i have a seconder
thanks andrew any discussion
all those in favor say aye
those against
that's carried right members information
exchange john will kick off with you
to my list um
i did attend the opening of the men's
shed in
uh woody the question
hasn't park and i also helped it up the
morning community centre for the flower
show
yep
pull it
getting old and silly um
yeah the um
the pc7
um decision from the the commissioners
comes to an extraordinary meeting of
ecan on november the 17th but it'll
actually be out in the agenda on
november the 11th which is when we
should be able to pick it up from the
agenda
um
and i presume we will have some response
to that um i went along
to the ashley rakahuri rating
um
meeting which they had earlier this year
instead of they usually have them all
sifton town theft and ashley ashley
river
they usually have them in the february
as an annual meeting but because of the
the flood repair
they had it in the middle of the year it
was very poorly attended i must say
there were two residents
the rest of them were all
staff from ecan myself
so i'm not quite sure how
how widely it
the invite
was circulated
i mean it's of concern to this board
because
they're actually planning a review of
the ashley rakahuri flood protection
scheme
they've been doing it for a while
so it hasn't gone anywhere but
it was really sobering to see that
at present that river is designed for a
flow of 2400 qmex
and at 1500 cumics at cones road they
were evacuating
and
little fred brooks who's the north
canterbury
regional
engineer said if it had got anywhere
near there they would have been i think
it was carnage was his word
so
they've been recommended since i think
it's
2007 and again in 2000 well might be
2003 in 2009
that the river should be able to take 3
000 qmex
um now updated to
3250 qmex
so
it can't clearly after um just about um
falling apart with
1500 and that was a thousand at the
gorge
when the
um
when the um measuring device went out
and then
coming in from okuku
and the tributary rivers so down at the
cones road it was 1500 and we were in
serious trouble
so
um they're proposing
a review
in fact they've already been under
review not that they've involved anybody
and there was quite a lot of um
uh it was
brought up
also round the zone committee table and
no one knew anything about it so the
criticism came back to ecan was that
then your consultation is poor if you
are seriously looking at this and it has
rather large rating
implications for
people that are rated for the river
and also people that aren't rated for
the river and this is probably half the
problem with it
and they're thinking interestingly which
i
don't support this but
they were
instead of
tackling increasing the rating area for
the the river um
they were talking about a general rate
across the region
now
we do that and i don't support that
either in the sense that
the people who are already rated for it
pay twice
because they pay again in the general
rate for this and it's the technique
when you when you've got a challenge
well this is my view if you've got a
challenge in extending a rating area
rather than tackle that
you do it in your general rate where it
gets lost
and if you do it across the region or
across well in this case it'll be across
the district i suspect
it is lost and
you should be dealing with it front up
because the people who benefit from it
pay for this
so i'm not quite sure exactly what ecan
proposal is
um
it's looks like it's um
it looks like it's under review there's
a build up of shingle
uh there's um exactly how they're going
to manage the whole thing
um and i don't know what their
consultation program is
in fact i don't think they know
really so just alerting everybody
um i think
they should have got the message that
there was
you know the water zone committee is
the
elected representatives of the community
and they knew nothing so hopefully they
got a bit of a message
about they need to upgrade their um
consultation when in fact it um
it comes to the point where there's a
proposal going out for
rating
um
the other thing i guess um
is those of you that are part of a an
environmental group should have got a
an invite to the waimakariri
environmental action networking forum
on which i'm
um cheering on november the 24th now
it's only if you're a part of a group
and it'll be
um you know
taranaki creek should i should have got
an
invite and that is to
across the district
inviting all community groups and
agencies
to try and get an understanding of what
people are doing where and whether we
can assist in some collaborative way or
whether
no not
the council so much but
is there a an ability to work together
for a better outcome
we don't even know who's doing what in
this district so the idea is to
invite everybody we can think of and
then have a round table about what are
you doing
uh what constraints you have
do you think it would be good to have
this meeting as a regular sort of thing
set up a database
and can we work together for a better
effect
so yeah no that's about me
thank you
ah thank you
i attended a zone five and six meeting
in christchurch
last month
um
and that's from councillors and mayors
around most of the south island the dia
were present as was alan pragnell who's
the architect of the three waters
reform
and his boss when introducing alan
referred to him as the antichrist
which could have been appropriate
because i think most people in the room
appear to be opposed to the reforms
um
bill bayfield
who is the
water regulator
had a zoom last month which was quite
interesting i didn't know bill bayfield
but he seems an interesting fellow and
pretty much a straight shooter from his
presentation
water plans which councils need to
provide it seem to me will be
self-certified
rather than being sent off somewhere to
be marked and boxes ticked so it sort of
flipped the
compliance around the other way
i've just come from a housing social and
affordable working group meeting which
simon is also on um that group's looking
at
housing needs in the district
partnership opportunities and what
options the council may have in that
space
neville atkinson is the chair the mayor
wendy doody
nicki millings and myself are the
elected representatives on that so we're
still fairly early days with that group
at the last meeting earlier this month
council confirmed the representation
review recommendation
there are no changes proposed to this
ward or board
and that's gone to the local government
commission and is open for objections
until the 8th of december
unfortunately the enc business awards
that i think i mentioned last month have
been cancelled
along with the kyapo and rangiora
christmas parades
and also christmas by the lake at
pegasus
so you'll miss out on the opportunity of
seeing me in a santa suit
um in case you were wanting to see that
um i attended some district plan review
planner sessions um
we had a good workshop the board um
on a submission to the district plan
review i thought that was
quite a good session
um
went to a gcp workshop uh which looked
at spatial planning
and were
a bit of a workshop to look at
identifying growth areas around
canterbury where they may fall
i went to mike o'connell's farewell
some of you may know mike he's left the
council and i think he's gone to ecan
but not a hundred percent sure
that does how you can no
ministry for the environment i knew it
was one of those
environmental
places
and the other news trevor alice is
leaving us shortly to go to dock
department of conservation
the good news was
some of the council met
mps duncan webb and sarah pallett
and
gave them a presentation on three waters
uh so that was interesting
uh sarah pallet is now the buddy mp for
this
district
um previously it had been duncan webb
so duncan must be busy sarah's new
so
we do hope to have a closer
dialogue with the labour mps
and also mps from the greens national
and
other parties
to keep dialogue open
so that's more release it from me
um i heard that we had the audience
association meeting last monday night
um and chris stacy's our new secretary
and he's um going really well so which
is really good together
and he's a right into it
going very good um
we had to can the hunger because it drew
to covert which was a bit of a shame
because it would have been our major
thing um
the at the meeting we discussed roading
again which seems to come up every
meeting so it just doesn't really stop
so we
uh dan ross one who's a you know was a
labor he wrote a letter to the minister
it was quite funny the letter he got
back was like the stand letter everyone
else gets that he didn't even exist or
that's what i thought from reading the
letter so which was interesting for a
guy that's probably going to stand again
in the next election so
i think he's two off being a list mp so
which is so if they got two resignations
he would be in there which is
um
i had a call about a resident someone
wanting to get their place resigned on
wooden beach road the beginning to
residential and i didn't really know the
answer but i suggested that they contact
the council or look at the um planned
i also had a call about some rubbish
being dumped in the hole
josh road
so i went down but couldn't get the
snapseed and sold to go but i'll go back
and do that again so it looks like tyres
and all sorts of i don't know whether
it's
contaminated or not but
i went and measured the signs for grant
for the welcome to what inside so i've
given them the specs for what we need
for that so that's walk in progress and
also had good feedback on stalker park
being opened um which is i think people
are
really pleased you've been in down there
and had to play andrew
no
let me know where
some of your
things just what's your overall sense of
how the district plan is going
in the community in terms of response to
a
draft
plan
they got 21 here last week at the
drop-in
at wooden community centre which is
actually very good particularly for the
wooden community centre because often we
just seem to struggle to get people here
there is that one
also going to be running
two sessions next week in pegasus
so one's on
oh god now i can't remember no not next
week yes yes next week oh god i'd have
to remember because they don't seem to
want to
publicize them either one is at the
community kappa which is on wednesday
which is 10 45
and
the 18th is it
16 the 16th of november from 6 to eight
pm at the pegasus community centre
so kaye
got dragged into trying to organize that
one so
um yeah it has been a wee bit of a
lots of hands and fingers in the pie i
think would be how i would describe it
and it has been
yeah i could probably count it in
hours how much time i have spent trying
to keep things
organized and trying to figure out what
is actually happening
um so
yeah there's
yeah there's the odd
one who's looking at you know zoning
that i've heard of simon
at the moment it's just such a big thing
and i i think in general people unless
they are looking
particularly at zoning they're just
yeah
overwhelmed i think there's just
between where we are in terms of coping
19 and
then
yeah and it's not anybody's fault i
think yeah i think it's just
it's such a big beast of a thing that
just if you're here
if there's any sentiment out there about
what's good what's not good yeah
yeah i mean i haven't even heard a lot
around the you know minimum lot size in
a rural you know environment there
hasn't been a lot around that so
okay
so that's
right the consultation projects we have
the district plan is out and that closes
on friday the 26th of november i mean
mark's done the right thing if somebody
has got a question then direct them to
the council to you know they can contact
a planner they can meet with a planner
the planning department has been very
good at that of making themselves
available to talk to individuals so
yeah
is there somewhere that you can sort of
look hang on just one moment
can i ask people to speak up
here
oh sorry sorry
it's just asking generally about the
proposed district plan and
you as elected members sorry i
should have used that um
whether there was any general comment
out there in the community about issues
that the proposed district plan has
has raised um just just wanted to get a
sense of that beyond perhaps beyond any
individual property owner issues is
there anything that we should be aware
of
but
don't get the sense that that
that is the case per se and probably uh
life with um
with covert and all that's gone with
that is just starting to wear a bit
um on people's um
attentiveness to that issue
mark i just wanted and i mean it may be
my what is my lack of knowledge of where
to look but how do you look to see
obviously if lens the zonings change on
a particular land how do you actually
see that to try and map the whole
picture of and i'll give the example as
um
gladstone road so obviously
jeffrey stop was all places sold to that
very lily so that zone residential the
next place along has um sold to the same
guy which i presume that zone
residential but i don't know how to see
that and i don't know where the planned
extra residential
you know full
404b but if someone can tell me how i
look for that because that would be
something would be
you can go online and on the let's talk
page
there's some links there's a link to the
e-plan you can plug in an
address it takes a few minutes to open
um you can plug in an actual address if
you want to see it and it will bring up
the map um
is there an overall map that shows that
oh yeah yeah i mean this is one
i was going to talk about later but this
is just
a specific area
sorry you can see that
i didn't see the map
online at an individual property level
and then you can zoom out and you get a
sense of the overall
scale of a zoning in a particular area i
think the issue that you raised mark
about well what was it like before
is more problematic because the old plan
was
um was was not very digital it was a
a pdf kind of map
this is more interactive
more flexible
but if you are wanting to know well what
was the zoning before
then um do ask a planner and they will
they will
tell you so if you go and you look at
that and then you're not happy with it
you could put a submission into correct
yeah either um yeah yes so if you've got
to i think the 26th of
and then and then individuals can do
that as well so correct
anyone and you can make a submission on
any property you like
it's a quirk of the new zealand planning
system that i could object to
the rezoning
in kai taya
and my submission will be julie
considered that was what the workshop i
didn't go to was about wasn't it
so are we planning to put submissions in
yeah i was going to talk about that at
the end but um yeah literally kay has
pulled together the notes from that
workshop um i've had a meeting kay and
i've had a meeting with trevor alice and
mark butler to ask some specific
questions so to clarify some things
we'll get something out to you but yeah
i'll expand on that a bit later it's
probably easier so yes we've got the
proposed district plan so he's please
refer people to a planner you know if
you're not sure if they've got questions
the planning you know team have been
wonderful they have made themselves
extremely available
so we've got the consultation project on
e-scooters which the trial is underway
um and the district parking strategy
which
i have had a quick look at but that's
about it
we can go online through um in the
office just sorry just to make you
envious if you
possibly would be and on the flamingo
site and
see what the daily traffic is and then
pull up a map to see where people are
traveling
so we will
as the trial progresses sort of produce
that that information and i think over
the weekend we had our first rangi aura
to woody and scoot
who was it
we can we can we can tell you who
so far
[Laughter]
it's really a question of they'll put
the scooters where the pattern is
beginning to emerge
i mean in one sense they're wanting to
maximize the revenue of the scooters so
they'll put more where they see there is
a greater propensity to use
but it's still a trial across all of all
of the centres so
i personally i think it's gone
been introduced with a lot less anxiety
than i might have thought
in the community because we were
certainly right at the beginning
there was a sense of a little bit of
trepidation
about
how will they be received in this
community with all of the negative
marketing that has happened with these
scooters but i think to be fair to
flamingo and i'm not pushing them
particularly but i think the companies
have learnt an awful lot in the last
year or so
about how to do this and
how to work with councils
and
we've been really pleased with their
attitude
there's nothing that we can do to stop
these scooters being
put out there
um
are they legal
but so the fact that they're working
with us we think is really positive
do you know how many they've actually
got in circulation because it was up to
four it was up to four hundred as the
trial yeah i think so i just wondered
how many that actually i don't i
mean that was one of my concerns it was
just a sheer number of yeah
sorry
just a question simon just curious am i
um allowed to park my car on the
footpath the car that i share with
dorothy
is that i'm just curious about the
legality of scooters both here in other
other cities i was another city of the
weekend and curious to see them just
how does that arise feedback into the
district parking strategy yeah
um so i think your car is a registered
motor vehicle or i hope it's registered
um and there are motor vehicle
regulations
okay and
e-scooters are not covered by that yeah
um so
i guess there are there's the there's
the swings and roundabouts of it in
terms of
us as a community getting used to a much
wider range of mobility devices
you know e-bikes e-scooters
[Music]
you see mobility scooters are becoming
more lean faster
so we're going to have to we've only got
the same amount of roads but a road
reserve we're going to have to try and
manage more and more devices and more
and more use of diverse devices
the thing that really gets me is those
guys who've got the hand controlled
skateboards and they're whizzing along
you know at 25 kilometers an hour
so i'm sorry i'll shut up in a minute
but
um
we are waiting for um a response uh
there was a consultation last year
during covert with
ministry for transport around the regime
for a lot of these new devices
and
the potential to
set speed restrictions in the like 15
kilometers i think is the limit there so
we were a little trepidatory about
launching the trial before that is in
place
but
we have a we had an operator who was
prepared to
trial it in the district
and and it is a trial we don't have to
accept their proposition at the end of
it
but are all going well
then it becomes
a an accepted part of the community
[Music]
thanks for that simon
right the board funding update we've got
the balances there we haven't spent
anything tonight so
media i'll come up with something
no questions understanding orders no
urgent general business
so i would declare this meeting closed
with the next meeting scheduled for 6 pm
on monday the 13th of december
here
so thank you very much
you